OH! OH! OH!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario Maker.
Now, I've calmed down since the last time
that I played this
and it's going to go much better!
Number One:
Full disclosure, I started a new-a new uh- thing, with Super Mario Maker
so I'm actually on a new 100 Mario Challenge.
And the reason I did that is because of the just pure DOUCHINESS of the laaaaast one.
Oh, what am I suppose to do with you?
AHHAHAHA-I didn't know that you were gonna bop!
Ahh- I thought I forgot about it.
Okay, so this level is called small to big
and it has to do with, like big world small world, like aH-UH why then?!
Why then, I'm off to such a bad start!
Okay, this has to do like small to big world, y'know like in Mario 64 tha-that cool level-
WHAAAT?
Whahahat?
Don't do this! Don't do this!
Chica it's okay!
Chica is wandering around all worried.
OH GODDAMNIT!
I'm just trying to be cool! I'm just trying to be cool!
Okay,
so from now on no more of-
OH! COME ON!
Oh my god!
I'm just trying to vff- live!
Chica it's okay!
I'm just- I'm just trying to live.
I'm just trying to live-
Chica's putting her head in my lap right now.
It's okay Chica.
I'm just trying- I'm just trying to live.
I'm just trying to live. (For the 5th time)
Okay, so now
we're going go about this calmly and collectively
and we're going to be 100% on it.
100%!
Because, we are cool individuals
who go into things,
calmly and collectively
without and panic in anything that we do-
[starts panicking] Oh god,
Oh gosh.
Oh gersh. Oooh gersh
Oooh gersh.. Oooh gersh..
OH ah oh oh gersh
Oh gersh, oh what do I do?
AHH uhhuhkay HUHUHHH
Okay, everything's fine.
I think I did the right move there.
Ah UAH NO AH I JUMPED uhhhh ahh
*relieved laughter*
*relieved laughter continues*
I thought that was gonna be it.
*relieved laughter continues* I was so scared.
I was so scared!
*even more relieved laughter*
Oh man. Oooh man. Oh wow.
Okay, but I'm doing wonderfully.
I'm doing phenomanenemaly
Whadda I?
Don't lie to me.
HUP
Okay.
You didn't lie to me didchya? No YOU DID NOT
YeeYES!
Yeahahahahaha ha
Okay, I am going to flyyy
through these expert levels. [Famous last words, Mark.]
I am going to do this better than you guys have ever seen Mario Maker done. [Famous. Last. Words.
Even though just in little bit, like two minutes ago
You saw it be done badly.
Like the worst you've ever seen.
And admittedly,
That's bad, but now
I'm going to get through this A-ok, because I am
Good at what I do an so long as it doesn't throw a
Whoa, what is happening?
What is happening? What's happening? I don't know what is happening!
What the hell?
What is going on?
Ah, Ah, okay.
Alright then, here we go.
What the fuck is going on?
What? [existential crisis]
What is this insanity? [Mario Maker] What am I supposed to be doing here?
Is there an answer to this?
Oh god. Do I go up here? Oh okay.
Can I get away from the madness?
NOPE
Okay.
Whoa!
How'd you get--hu, How'd yew... How did ju
Oh god, I'm not supposed to be down here, I'm not supposed to be down here, I'm not supposed to be down here, I'm not supposed to be down here,
I'm not supposed to be down here, I'm not supposed to be-
Oooohkay.
Oooohkay
Oohkay
*lip smack*
Pfffsstry this again. I suppose.
I suppose.
Okay.
*Mark trying to process the level*
Oohkay.
I'ma restart.
'Cuz something went horribly wrong therherherher
What the hell..happened?
Okay, so obviously.
I'm not supposed to...
Ien noht supposed to go that way.
Supposed to go...
supposedtch do sum
There we go, got em good.
Okay, I'm gonna go through the door now.
'cuz I don't know what else I'm doing with my
Hellooo. Hi. How's it going everybody?
I'm just wondering through, don't mind me. Okaay.
What the fuuuck is happening here?
Wha-hut
Huhu
Huho
Uh huh
Huhuhu
Huhuhuhu
*laughter*
*even more laughter*
*and more*
Okay.
Alright then, can I just...
Oooh, I can just grab it.
I didn't know that.
Alright then.
Nooo, okay. You know what?
This.. This one's a madhouse.
Hello!
Hi, whattam I, whoaeyeyewhat's happening?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
Okay Goodbye... goodbye world!
God damn it.
Why do I have to get all the weird levels?
What the hell happened to this?
What happened to fun, normal, good old fashion levels... where... [Don't you remember last episode, Mark?]
Ah, there was a star there.
That's how I got that.
Okay. Well, shi-, fuck.
God damn it.
Well alright then. You know what? Ihuhuh I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Let's just go, let's try this again. Hello, hi buddies.
Hop, okay so that's how I got that.
Uh that's
Goodbye, okay, now I got this.
Goodbye to you.
Alright, cool.
Goodbye to you, goodbye to you.
Just gonna get outta-- whoop, that's.. that looks good.
Why did you get evil when you had a spin jump in you?
NO!
NOOO!
NO GET OUT OF THERE!
There we go.
Thank you.
Hehm.
Take the the evil away from you. The evil out of your soul.
haaaaaBOINK
mkay
So if I can jUUuust...
Make my way downtown, walking fast
Moving pass and I'm homebound
Over this way
well shit.
woa shit.
wooshet
C'mon!
Do the th- Duth-
OH, I can- Ooh, okay.
I neeeeeed that.
Ok, so I just need to get out of there in time before it's all-
kerfuckled
kerfucklinated
That's a technical term.
k, thank you!
euh!
Too slow, too south
okay
HEP!
There we go.
WOOO! Okay.
I'm outta here, babeh!
I'm outta here!
Lemmie take care of you guys,
You arseholes first.
Ah, fuck your nut.
*sounds of concentration*
Okay, now I'm sure enough-
YEAA, I got hehehit!
Everything worked out great!
WE GOT ANOTHER ONE!
Oh, we are doing wonderfully, we are blazin-
I'm outta water!
Allllright.
Kewwwl.
He's sooo sad.
*inhale*
But at least we're alive.
And that's all that matte- I almost broke the record
With my slow ass I almost broke the record on that son'abitch.
On a level threeee!
That was only two...?
Holy shiit.
I forgot I skipped one.
God damnit.
*sigh*
I need to calm down.
What is this shit?
Wasn't I supposed to do that?
Seems like something I was supposed to do.
I mean...
juss- just sayin'.
I kinda- You don't need to be laughing at me when I'm doing the right thing.
How about if I go over it?
What's gonna happen if I do that?
Is this going to be a baaad?
Is this gonna be bad for me?
Is this gonna be baaad?
It's gonna be bad. It's not gonna work, is it?
It's not gonna work.
It's a big- WoOOAH it WORKED!
Hohaha!
It worked?
Did I get the right one?
On the first try??
I think it's going- Oh my gahahad!
Things are going well for me!
Oh, how I'm-
Noo...
Okay...
Oooh, okaaay.
Alr- Oooh, okaay!
HAAA!
Hihiyeaahehehehehehaa!
YEAHEHA!
Okay. Alright.
Okay!
I got it! I'm doing it!
*tears of joy* Things are going well for me!
sphtsh
*more tears of joy*
*and more*
Okay.
*sniff*
Everything's fine.
This is going beautifully.
Heh.
Okay.
Spikes and falls. I don't like the sound of that because I've got horrible horrible horrible memories of spikes.
Don't.
Even.
Do nothing.
TO ME!
'RIP'
Fff- uuuudge.
How am I supposed to get around you?
Am I supposed to pop in in one of you, then steal one of your... ballooooonz?
There's gotta be way
HOP!
NOPE!
UUUUUGH, fuck.
Okay, so... gotta be a liiiiittle more cautious about a lotta people that played this level.
But there's gotta- thn- Then that means that there's a good- good basis of players who have been through this.
Heelll! Goddamnit!
A little too much.
I'm trying to get a run in starter like pause before I go to each next one
Because that's gonna get me low enough that I don't hit them.
Oh shet!
Why did I go right of the bat?
I was so eager to death.
I was so eager to embrace death.
Chica it's ok!
Everything's fine, don't worry about it, I got this under control.
This one I got!
WOA-woah, hey buddy
Friend?
Ok this one...HOP!
Ahhhhhh ffffffff-
Sassafras.
I gotta wait just like a little bit longer on that one-
Chica what do you have?!
Do you have one of my socks?!
Chica LEAVE IT!
LEEEEEAVE IT!
Ebth-Oooooah gaaaah
I've got fuckernutted.
Chica!
What have you done?
Chica LEAVE IT!
LEAVE IT!
Hey! Leave it-
Wroooooong!
Gud.
Good job.
She's smart, she's getting smart.
She's not-INCREDIBLY smart
I don't wanna give her too much benefit but,
Ya know, she's good enAUUUough
Faaaaaaaaack
I had an opportunity there
I hesitated in midair
I just went back a little bit
It's okay Chica!
I still love you!
Just don't eat my socks!
Hip.
HOOOOP
Hup-no!
Get outta the way! (x1)
Get outta the way! (x2)
Get outta the way! (x3)
Get outta the way! (x4)
Get outta the way! (x5)
Yea-OOOOOOOH!
YEEEEAH!
OH! OH! OH! OH! OH! OH! OH! OH! OH!
*out of breath*
*joyous laughter*
Yeah Chica yeah!
I diiiiiid iiiiiiiiit!
WOOOOOOOOOOOH!
New record?!
Fackyeaaaah!
Someone said it was the worst level ever
Bullsh*t I got that on lock!
*sniff*
Now let's embarrass myself in the next episode,
right Chica?
Goooooood.
Very goooood.
VEEEERY good
I'm just gonna try this a couple times-
"Bowser's Endcastle."
That doesn't sound good.
At least they're giving me things!
I always like it when I get things!
OH you're nat a-
Wha-that's-
Uhh.
Uh.
Aww man.
But I trusted....
...so hard for me to trust again.
Ah goddamnit!
It waz gonna give me a thing!
It might be a good thing,
I see one pixel o'red
That seems like a good thing!
Alright.
I got this.
It's okay Chica!
I love you!
I love you lots!
*kissing noises*
okay-WOOP!
Okay!
Gad! Fffw-Fwrick dammit!
Itsza frick!
Ye sonova frick!
Okay.
Let's try this again!
With less SUCK
I've got,
dubious amounts of suck.
Oh ok-WOA!
Hello!
Wa-godammit!
ooOOAHh I made it!
I didn't know how I made it!
Can I get-YEEEES!
Thank you! Yes! I needed this
For many tough and things!
(Correction) Stuff and things!
Wooahiythatseeohawoiuio
okay.
Can you please?
Thank you!
Woah god I am all-
I shouldn't have taken so many shrooms maaan!
No one's ever made THAT joke.
Oh it even had an arrow of
Where I'm supposed to be going,
That's awfully convenient of it!
I didn't think it was going to be NICE to me
Hey look! I've got even more stoofs!
Ya gonna do something?
Why would you go that way you dick?
HUP
Okay, here we go, GOODBYE!
Huh-THAAAAT'S not what I was looking for!
Wooooah-kay.
Alright, g'bye then!
HWOP!
Okay!
OOOoah what's happinin?!
What's happinin bro?
Well-that was,
That was clutch.
Ah! Sheet.
This one?
I believe you!
I'm trusting you!
It was right the last time,
why would they mess with me?
Hello
Can I have this?
Okay,
I'm just gonna leave that there.
Okay!
Everything's fine!
Chica what are you doing you crazy pup?
She's rubbing her face all over everything.
eh, eh
Oh NOOOOOOOO!
OH NO IT WAS RIGHT THERE I SHOULDA LOOKED
EEEEEEEEENGH
WHY DIDN'T IT HAVE ANY-
ERNZGAAAWD!
okay.
I'm gonna pick this up in the next video,
I'm all outta time for this one so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Cheer me on in the comments because
I'm gonna do it this tiiiiiime!
With,
vim and vigor.
It's gonna go better for me!
Thanks again, and as always,
I'll see YOU,
IN the next video!
BUH-BYE!
[Crazy la Paint]